Madonna is giving fans a rare Glimpse at
all six of her kids in one photo it's
fantastic I'm very lucky over the
weekend the singer gave an inside look
at her Thanksgiving celebration
featuring all kinds of snaps with her
kiddos my children moved me and their
best looks that was a fun moment for
them check out 26 year old Lourdes also
known as Lola next to 22 year old Rocco
and 17 year old David standing behind
his mom she adopted him back in 2008
from an orphanage in Malawi Madonna also
adopted 16 year old Mercy a year later
fast forward eight years now
ten-year-old twins Stella and Astaire
joined the family too the 64 year old
singers got quite the full home it's
very very theatrical at my house and
while she doesn't give insight into her
kids lives too often earlier this month
Madonna shared a video with David
jamming to Beyonce's move
[Music]
I know
the thing you'll do will be held against
you
[Music]
and check out a stairs DJ skills as she
mixes mom's 2000 hit music
[Music]
everything happens
um pretty organically seems she's not
the only family member putting her
talents on display I'm very proud of her
of course and I just I I don't I want
all my kids to be creative but whatever
they end up doing is fine with me and
like my mom has helped me so much she
like she has great style she's an
amazing dresser Lola's made her Mark in
the fashion world as a model even
snagging a spot in Rihanna's Savage X
Fenty runway show last year
[Music]
she's way more talented than I am than I
was am whatever so I'm really proud of
her plus she's following in her mom's
footsteps she dropped her first song in
August
[Music]
[Music]
now one thing is for sure for this proud
mama nothing beats enjoying the holiday
season with her kids of course
foreign